[Music]
in too soon news Wow
take it easy s too soon submitted by
wash your rice you should you really
should have you guys never made rice
with that Washington I've never even
cared to try dared to try no I didn't
know about washing rice until I make
Casey oh the Mexican people in my life
that I have ever seen Chi hope I'm the
first one because we always wash our
hands and I've never seen people watch
it I'm your first you can use the rice
water as skin stuff to make your skin
softer really no but thank you no that's
not what I do but you haven't made rice
in a while but you can do that you don't
wash your beans yes we wash the bed
sound like a judgmental question why
don't you wash the rice if you wash your
beans I don't know that's just the way I
grew up I don't know that's what I saw
like my mom my aunt like sometimes there
might be bugs or something whenever I
would watch them cook no one ever washed
the rice
it was always dry rice that they would
use to cut if you don't wash your rice
dude just like you said there's always
bed bugs in there something so when I
watch they think the [ __ ] top and you
rinse it off wash you're right there
there's the arsenic thing too and you
want to get rid of some of that starch
so it stays a little fluffy there's a
stick so much so it's not glutinous you
have a number tell I do it three times
it depends you need it to stick yeah
you're supposed to look at the water
I'm telling you clear cuz it never gets
clear it does if you wash it enough wow
how many times of that when you make
sushi rice you have to make sure that
you do that [ __ ] to that waters clears
[ __ ] so you don't want any of that
because already short grain rice is
already glutinous and this is enough as
it is yeah so you want it to have that
gluten content while still being sticky
but not too sticky so you have to do it
to the waters clear so washing machine
Wow they should make one a rice washing
machine oh yeah that's awesome Essene
what's the one she's racist
a racist or Isis a woman sent wedding
invites before her boyfriend proposed
what in the [ __ ] psycho totally
errant is expensive they are people
gotta text for me me too actually
wait why are physical copies now I think
it's very they're like postcards and
stuff right it's like an even funnier
though you put on their fridge so I
throw that [ __ ] immediately with
definitely car especially because a
Marie Kondo no she goes its spark joy
toss it out the way yeah because if not
that's a minus 30 of them in right now
in my house yeah you know that's cuz
y'all are friends you know somebody
friend I like to keep friends forever
dude is not my fault I do at a distance
friends forever at a distance how you
doing what's up that's all I need but I
had I've had said no to a lot of wedding
stuff yeah okay we get it you're gonna
say no are you like sorry I can't
are look you did you did mention though
that some people use you for like clown
stuff so it feels weird and I always get
offensive I always get offended by that
not because they're trying to use me for
clout is how low of a human being are
you to invite a Z list celebrity like
because you're not even yeah like dude I
might get the lowest totem pole of a
celebrity you should set your sights a
little [ __ ] higher you trash bag
what's wrong with you like what are you
gonna do yes maybe absolutely none of
you so if you were a mystery would it
would change your perception about them
yeah I would be like you know what dude
you're right you should have liked me
but then you're gonna get pissed cuz you
the week you're gonna be like they're
[ __ ] using me again yeah yeah they're
really using me so how how I do it now
is based on I know this is wrong but
it's ethnicity much because if you based
on ethnicity it depends on the type of
food this cup the food and the fun time
food so if it's if it's a Vietnamese
wedding 100% I'm going we're talking
about anything would it let your friend
Hennessey at every [ __ ] table we're
talking about Heinekens and we're
talking about [ __ ] salt and pepper
crab we're talking about Doug
and we're talking about mama's booty
right such a yeah and they all dance we
get [ __ ] [ __ ] as a mother [ __ ] and
it's a great time you are a friend who
says listen I'm gonna have a violinist
there [ __ ] your wedding I'm not going to
that show yeah one of the best wings
ever went to [ __ ] Tim's that should
have hiked this [ __ ] it was yeah churros
ice-cream DJ so changing the song every
15 seconds yeah keeping it felt the
crowd yeah you so good
so yeah this woman here she so a friend
of this woman posted on Facebook saying
what a [ __ ] friend saying I love my
friend dearly and her boyfriend of a few
years is really an awesome guy I love
hanging out with them but sometime after
New Year's Day she did a Facebook game
that told her that she's getting married
this year as one of those fake fortune
games oh I could see a wedding for them
happening sometime though and so she
ended up messaging me on Instagram today
to RSVP for a special event which is
when I realized she's really been
planning her wedding wait
oh I feel like my arms are gonna fall
off how would she know the date of the
wedding if he hasn't proposed and he
hasn't exactly I don't know she's just
kind of planned ahead kind of well she
probably picked her date so she's like
if it's happening soon maybe this year
then I want it to be next year around
like summer or whatever hmm
I hate this I feel bad I feel for I feel
bad for the guy well this friend is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] about
away but I do want a dope reception
mMmmm what is the wedding part then well
I'm confused already by the ceremony
part I could just have it at City Hall
or whatever
yeah the reception I want all my friends
to have fun right so I don't know how
Mariel feels about this but I don't want
best man speeches I don't want any of
that [ __ ] on everybody I'm gonna make
the [ __ ] speech thank you for coming
you stupid [ __ ] thank you for
celebrating with me now we got this live
band everybody better [ __ ] dance get
drunk and eat good food leave it at that
yeah what is it happening nice don't
[ __ ] it but I'm getting nervous now
I'm sweaty he's hot i'ma buy some for
your wedding you might have like an
alligator you might have a ceremony -
for her family suggestion and they want
to go through the yeah yeah so we're -
probably have to do that
oh so ha I got your back David I mean
Mexican foot or fart like a [ __ ]
during church wait I'm totally gonna
punish Gio I'm sitting with you guys
wherever the [ __ ] you guys are
absolutely in the front I'll be at the
reception you guys had the bit soon
we'll be everything at the baby-making
night to blogging oh that's what we're
doing time out time out
we've had it cut already legs higher
finger up make sure she's sitting on the
pillow how do you go eggs you're always
watching this video were like in the
Amazon right there's this tribe and then
when when it was like the wedding night
for the couple the elder like the woman
right yeah she comes in and she watches
them to make sure they're they're
[ __ ] right what does that even mean
Oh certain angles yeah maybe he's
sticking it in an ass and [ __ ] you know
like he doesn't know that's a good one
cuz remember that one Chinese couple
that we talked about they've been trying
to get pregnant [ __ ] Iraq yeah
they're like I just it's been like three
years we don't know why we're not
getting pregnant that's funny no doctors
would ever assume that they're sticking
in the wrong hole
yeah funny if they're like I seen so
many pornos and I tried coming on her
face so many times but she's never
pregnant
oh my god maybe swish it in your mouth
and keep it in there longer yeah like
what if they think that's how you
actually gotta go pregnant
who the Mel look to the face because
they watch too much porn then gargle it
and then spit it out I know that's so
crazy
what are we talking about wait why did
you say her it's [ __ ] up for her
friend well cause her friends putting
her on blast aeronaut dirty laundry she
didn't mention her name does it matter
that's the [ __ ] up all sort of like
you news like if you new in the circle
of friends yeah I would never put any of
my friends [ __ ] online like that cuz
that's their [ __ ] like I'll be like that
[ __ ] crazy but she could be crazy about
private life always put my friend [ __ ]
out online but I used to fake names oh
my god and then I slightly switched this
story just because when I first started
doing you know I did all those like blah
stuff and then I kind of realized that
because one from is such a small town
did everyone know there's pretty easy to
find out oh no I have to switch like 20
percent of the story just so it gets
like a little diluted and I'm you know
you know me I keep a lot of my friends
from back in the day so it's like I
started feeling bad so if you guys ever
hear stories about a hundred percent of
the time it's all fake names you're
never gonna know the actual names but
this is do you say stuff that makes the
person look bad depends
do they ever know that you're talking
about them when they when you switch
that your name not really no one's ever
confronted you well it's because most
people don't buy their own [ __ ] when
they [ __ ] up they don't think it's that
ah so have you said stories about us and
switched it enough your guide to stuff
because you guys are already out in the
public eye so you can't do that alright
as always don't watch the vlogs and know
the truth that Dave is lying there like
wait a minute that part is not made
karte karte one what scarred blonde dude
what about Hyo Kwan I know he'll blonde
[Laughter]
yeah that's not very smart yeah I mean
and if you do care about those people
then you should mask them if you don't
give a [ __ ] about them then whatever
right and then repercussions are not I'm
gonna [ __ ] about you either way sir well
you told that story I hate you of course
until this so what the [ __ ] are you
talking about dude did this boyfriend
find out I don't know I want to know
more about the story too I want to know
his reaction
yeah what would he just bring did it
yeah what do you propose you know like
what if Mario started sending out
wedding invites what would you do that
song I probably just propose a real fast
because the he loves our now yeah no but
yeah I mean we don't know this situation
yeah I mean my situation is a little
different I suppose that I'd be like
okay well you're sending it out but
we're not gonna have that wedding at
that time like what the [ __ ]
like I'm I've been with there not for
four years like if she got pregnant now
I wouldn't care it's like it's my kid I
mean I wouldn't freak out she probably
freaked out but I love it yeah I'm like
hey daddy did yes pop in the baby out
yeah I wish I wish we knew how long they
were together no me too probably really
short
that means she's probably gonna be a
bridezilla then cuz of control freak oh
sure heshes like one of those weird
situations where I always find it weird
when the guy proposed to the girl that
she goes no it's like well how shitty
was your relationship that you didn't
know that she didn't want to get married
ray yeah I would pretty it was your
relationship that guy didn't [ __ ] know
well so in that situation our
relationship was so shitty that he
wanted to make sure that I couldn't
leave well that's not gonna do it I know
so it was more like let me trap her hey
I know I [ __ ] like punched you in the
face yesterday but come on but yeah it
was just like four years old like I want
to break up with you and then it led to
okay will you marry me you public and it
couldn't I
I was quartered and you know old Tiffany
oh that's right into deep
which restaurant wonder that it was I
thought it was a nice place
Taco Bell annoying Zippy's in Hawaii
wait so in any really yeah and then
right now either one month a month later
I was like fancy place called cities the
most fanciest place in town you're going
to say no to me [ __ ] [ __ ] where
Zippy's right I know look what I did I
even got you the [ __ ] cheesecake I
know I [ __ ] put it inside my spam
musubi and everything I surprise you
[Music]